I have a question about leadership I'm a
firefighter
and some of the guys on my department
have been pushing me to step up and put
in for an opera officer's position and
I'm honored but when we're one when we
were going to a call I was presented
with an opportunity to lead and passed
it up I don't know what I was thinking
I can't believe I did that did I just
lose credibility if I did is there a was
to get back that back away right that's
what he meant yeah if I did is there a
way to get that back Thanks okay so
first of all this is just a general rule
if you want to lead always be ready to
lead right be ready to step up make sure
you're not stepping on people's toes as
always but be ready to lead and the way
you do that is you think about you what
you do in certain situations you should
always be thinking about that you'd be
thinking even if you were a trooper or a
follower in a certain situation you
should think okay how would I leave what
would I do right now what moves where I
make what would I do if a contingency
happened right now and what are the
possible contingencies that I could be
looking at what are they and if you're
thinking that as a as a frontline guy
win the opportunity pops up then just
jump on it boom there you go then when
it does happen of course you got to stay
detached because you want to make sure
that you don't leave too far you don't
overstep your bounds and step on toe so
you got to be careful that so you need
to live with that mindset and that will
make you such a a better leader when the
moment does come if you're always
thinking about if you're always watching
like you talked about earlier I'm
watching the leader I'm seeing what
they're doing I'm seeing what I might do
differently I'm still supporting them
I'm supporting you if you're in charge
I'm supporting you but I'm thinking I
might I might do this and then you watch
what would my what would the results of
my decision have been compared to what
they did so you you can be thinking like
leader even though you might not
necessarily be in a leadership position
hmm so live with that mindset that's
what you need to do now as far as you
passing up the opportunity to lead
which guess you're admitting wasn't
error first of all say there's a
probably it's probably not quite as
obvious to everyone else as it is to you
in your mind you're thinking oh man I
blew it this was my chance and problem
no I bet the guys went back from that
call and didn't even think about it
didn't even think about it again most
likely unless it was just some flake
right now I don't want to lead I'm not
ready if you did that well then yeah
people are gonna but if you just said if
you just kind of backed away from a
moment and people people might have
realized it but anyways regardless of
that you probably guess what I'm gonna
say then what you gonna do is I want it
right you gotta own it
mm-hm so when the opportunity presents
itself to explain what happened and what
went wrong and what you did wrong right
not making excuses but explain where you
were weak you know so you say hey guys
you know hey remember that last call I
should have stepped up and I had the
didn't have the wrong mindset I wasn't
ready to lead and I let not only that
let you guys down I let myself down and
I'm not gonna let that happen again from
now on I'm gonna have leadership in the
front of my mind that's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna be thinking about what
needs to get done I'm gonna be thinking
about contingencies and how I'm gonna
lead and I promise the next time this
opportunity comes up I'm gonna be ready
to lead so I'm sorry for letting you
guys down won't happen again okay that's
that's it boom mm-hmm get the mindset
live and think as a leader regardless of
what position you're actually in and
then when they call you and the
opportunity presents itself step up and
lead obviously that's your default
mindset now it is truly was it always
like that and even before it's that
story that I've told over and over again
about being on an oil rig and coming up
and guys not know where to go everyone
freezing and and me going okay I'm just
step back and look around and make a
call and when I did that that was it hmm
and so I I when it clicked it clicked or
I would
I guess I was thinking about it
beforehand because I was you know
observing my leaders and thinking about
what they were doing and what I would do
differently in a certain situation yeah
yeah that's crazy because even in
everyday life which is what I represent
everyday life but you know how your wife
or girl whatever it's like hey you know
what's the dinner situation Oh what do
you want oh I don't care whatever you
want you know that's a time where I
always feel this what this guy just
asked you know I mean obviously it's
nothing compared to his situation but
like hey well you know what do you think
for dinner kind of thing and I'm like
hey I don't I don't care and that's
really how I feel I don't care I'm kind
of down for whatever and the thing but
that's not why that's not why she's
asking me she wants me she wants me to
make that decision she want you to step
up and lead step up and be like this is
what we're having for dinner I'm gonna
go get her I'm gonna make it or whatever
that's what she wants and there's no
that situation comes up on it that's a
good like you know the old that the Jo
actually that's kind of like a joke you
know when you ask the girl when a girl
says or when you have to go hey what do
you want to eat and she don't I don't
care whatever and then you say okay
we're gonna go eat hearing today and I
really like of course see ya
you gotta yeah I feel like this guy when
I do that though that's the point there
so from now on you're gonna step up and
lead I'm gonna do it yes but I want it
to be my default is why you know like
yours is like your default like oh this
what we're doing okay you know what I
wish that was true with her when it did
come to dinner actually you know it kind
of is true cuz I only go to like three
places to eat
yes and I go to one eighty percent of
the time
yeah thanks or the other twenty percent
of the time so she says where you want
to go I'm going to say that my
restaurant yeah we're gonna Raglan's and
Obie does she like Raglan's though she
does oh yes easier yeah but and if she
doesn't feel like it then she'll be like
I don't really want to go there okay
cool now it's on you I gave you my vote
right no you don't want to do that but I
think you've still got to do it
you still got to make a decision you
gotta like cuz in a way I'm in the same
boat as your second scenario they're
like if she's not in there so I like
then I just gonna name my secondary
restaurant all right there you go maybe
she'll say yes maybe she'll say no well
that got to be my default now though all
right step up and lead yeah you know
what I mean what I got to do I got to
prepare I got to prepare myself well
yeah I gotta have like five options just
ready to go on deck that's what I have
three so that's not yeah and they all
come in the same order I must be really
boring
hey you focus on what's important that's
good
well whenever my wife says uh you know
don't you ever want to try anything new
no yeah and I don't I don't yeah
speaking of which darling you're my girl
anything yeah I'm at my happy the same
thing very happy yes that's actually
that I'm gonna use that there but what
do you do when the team wants to try
something new all right let's rock all
right let's do that
all right good tips